so we haven't watched a ton of cable
news recently but we assumed with mass
layoffs underway across the US economy
and egg shortage crumbling cities the
prospect of a third world war looming on
the near Horizon we assumed we knew what
the other channels would be covering
because they're an awful lot of threats
out there
what we didn't know until we tuned into
MSNBC and CNN the other day was that all
of those threats go by a single name
and that name
is Mr George Santos George Santos
weeks into his new job as a freshman
member of Congress and just months from
his previous life of near total
anonymity George Santos has somehow
transformed into the single most
dangerous and historically significant
figure on the global stage today
George Santos is like 9 11 in human form
nothing will ever be the same now that
George Santos is here you will never
forget the moment you first saw George
Santos where were you when George Santos
was elected it's a story you will tell
your grandchildren watch
on Capitol Hill this is George Santos's
reality it seems almost every day there
are new questions about the Freshman
congressman's past some stretching back
more than a decade can you keep up with
all the Santos lies and controversies he
is now out trumping Trump in terms of
flooding The Zone with excrement not
just saying that he played volleyball
but he had a scholarship that he slayed
teams from Harvard and Yale the perfect
portrayal of self-loathing
that he clearly is so disgusted with
himself and so disgusted with the life
that he's led a life of Lies a life of
fables people didn't decide because they
thought he was somebody totally totally
different it was a lie and a fraudulent
election he has to resign not a
Volleyball Champion and he doesn't
appear to be a champion of the people
either the voters did not elect you Mr
Santos they elected a version of you
invented by your imagination sadly
George Santos represents so much that is
wrong today lies denial
and the death of Shame
it was a stolen election it was a stolen
election you heard Adam kinzinger say it
and CNN filled in the blanks it's not
just that George Santos claimed that he
once played volleyball in college played
volleyball in college
it's worse than that indescribably worse
George Santos told other people out loud
and CNN can exclusively confirm this
that he had a volleyball scholarship
perhaps the most coveted credential in
Collegiate Sports
but he didn't
it was all a facade
it was a tissue of Lies constructed to
deceive the American people
there was no volleyball scholarship
there was not a single dollar of
volleyball scholarship
George Santos made it all up out of
whole cloth out of thin air
George Santos is an ursatz volleyball
player
a fraud a ghoul people voted for this
man believing he had played Collegiate
volleyball
on a scholarship and he hadn't
and yet tonight ladies and gentlemen
this thief of volleyball Glory
strides the halls of the United States
Congress unimpeded by law enforcement
it's like another insurrection
and by the way we are hearing tonight
we can't confirm this but we'll continue
our investigation in George Santos
there are reports tonight that he did
not actually work at Citibank
he did not work at Citibank no
volleyball scholarship never worked at
Citibank what percentage of the people
who voted for George Santos under false
pretenses would have done so had they
known he never played volleyball and
never worked at Citibank we can only
guess obviously a very small percentage
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight